We now would like to apply
our energy momentum rule
and momentum to analyze
a one-dimensional elastic
collision with no
external forces.
Let's remind ourselves,
we'll call it
the energy momentum equation
said that V relative initial
was equal to V relative final.
So we have V1x initial
minus V2x initial--
that's the x component of
initial relative velocity--
is equal to the
final x component
of the relative velocity.
And that was our
energy momentum law.
Now the momentum condition
that it's constant
was our equation V1x initial
plus m2 V2x initial equals m1
V1x final plus m2 V2x final.
Now let's see how this linear
system is much, much easier
to solve.
Let's look at the same
problem that we solved
before where m2 was equal 2m1.
And also, we were in
the laboratory frame,
so V2x initial is 0.
And that tells us that
the initial velocity,
relative velocity, is simply
the velocity of object 1.
So let's just write our
two equations down again
and see how much
simpler our system is.
V1x x initial is minus
V1x final plus V2x final.
So we have minus plus.
And our momentum condition,
remember V2x initial is 0.
The m1 and 1, m2 will be 2m1.
So we can cancel our m1s.
And we get V1x initial
equals V1x final.
And m2 is twice m1, so there's
a factor plus 2V2x final.
Now I want to solve for
our target variable.
I look at these two equations.
I can see almost immediately
that if I add these two
equations, V1x
initial will cancel.
And I get very simply by
adding, we get 2V1x initial.
And this is 3V2x final.
Or V2x final is 2/3 V1x initial.
And let's just call
this equation 1 and 2.
So we added.
And now to find V1x final,
let's see what we'll do there.
So we can do this a
variety of different ways.
I think the simplest
thing here to do,
we could eliminate V2x final by
multiplying through by minus 2.
Or we can simply substitute
in V2x final right here.
And we get-- so let's do that.
Let's substitute
that in right there.
And we get V1x initial
equals V1x final
plus 2 times 2/3 V1x initial.
When we bring that over to
the other side, 1 minus 4/3
is minus 1/3 V1x initial
equals V1x final.
And at the cost of
introducing a new concept,
we've found the algebra
much, much simpler
to solve in this problem.
And we can just double
check our result
that the initial velocity,
relative velocity,
was simply Vx1.
And the final relative
velocity, V relative final,
is minus V1x final
minus-- let's see,
the final relative velocity
is V1x final V2x final i hat.
And when we put that in, we
have minus 1/3 V1x initial
minus 2/3 V1x initial i hat.
And we have minus V1x
initial i hat, which
is minus V relative initial.
And so we see that the
relative velocity simply
changed direction.
This approach is
much, much easier.
And keep in mind that the energy
momentum and the momentum laws
are just rewriting our
two fundamental constants
of motion, kinetic
energy and momentum.